i'm probably gonna piss a lot of people
off in this video and that's not my
intention but
you come here for the uh unaltered you
know raw truth uh and so that is what
i'm going to try and provide you
just fyi my name is oxford rosie i own
acquisition.com we do about 85 million a
year in revenue and i have nothing to
sell you so
one of the biggest things that i talk
about all the time on this channel in
terms of how to grow is that there are
three different components to growing
your business right you have your skills
as the entrepreneur you have your
character traits as the entrepreneur and
you have your beliefs and what happens
is most people continue to add potential
to their business but do not grow their
business because they're not focused on
the thing that is the constraint and
that's kind of the fundamentals of the
theory constraint is that a system will
grow to its constraint and no further
basically you grow until you are
bottlenecked and then that bottleneck
becomes the weak link in the chain so to
speak and then you cannot grow past it
and so people do all these other things
which add potential they add strength to
the other aspects of the chain they had
they refortify other aspects of the
bridge but not the weakest point and so
they actually never
make more money and they stay because
they have not attacked the constraint
and so last night
i was at a dinner um with a couple of
entrepreneurs young doing a couple
million bucks a year and
their constraint was so evident to me
that i figured i would make a video
about it because i think it will be
helpful for you as well
and so there's two things that i want to
bring up uh and what's interesting is
that as i you know when i talk to
younger entrepreneurs i would say
younger being with quotes less
experienced whatever entrepreneurs their
out points are clearer and what i mean
by that is the red flags the things that
are limiting them are clearer to me than
say people who are further along right
and so with this particular uh couple of
entrepreneurs the limiter were two
things they were both based on character
traits and so i thought that you know a
lot of times i talk about skills i talk
about beliefs but i don't talk about
character traits as much and i thought
this would be a useful example for this
a couple of the statements they said
throughout the dinner really
rubbed me the wrong way not personally
but just in terms of me looking out for
another entrepreneur
um they made i am statements which are
in my opinion some of the most powerful
statements that you speak over yourself
about what you believe to be true right
and so they said uh we are high anxiety
people we uh have lots of anxiety
and i i don't even like saying it like
myself to make this video for you
because of how much i i hate
that type of statement the second thing
i heard later on in the conversation
they said something to the degree of um
i'm an all or nothing type person like i
either have to you know go full send
mode when i go out or i can't drink uh
or a different example of that same
concept would be like i either have to
you know train really hard and
and you know take take all the
supplements right in the in the meantime
or i or i just sit on the couch and eat
oreos right
and when i heard both of these things
and there were other traits that they
brought up but these are the ones that
i'm just remembering off the top of my
mind i
paused and i was like do you believe
that that do you think that belief
serves you they're like what do you mean
i was like
do you think that that belief serves you
that you are all or nothing that you
will have to go full send mode or you
have to stay in
they're like well hadn't really thought
about it like that the thing is is that
when we make these statements and the
thing is maybe the further on in the
game you go and this is why i think
mentors and having people outside of you
to speak into your life that you trust
is very useful because they can hear you
speak these limiting statements over
yourself right
um and i've told this story before in
the past but i'll say it again i used to
tell people that i was bad at math most
people now would never can say that i
was bad at math people would say i'm
pretty good at math right and i thought
i was bad at math until i was 26. think
about that for a second like 12 26 i
thought i was bad at math like isn't
that crazy right and i say this because
there are so many beliefs that we we
speak over ourselves these traits that
we claim to have we claim them right as
though they are ours but they are not in
order to grow your identity must be
whatever is required to grow
period that's it so if this season of
your life requires you to be more
assertive then you would say i have a
tendency based on external circumstances
to be more assertive in these types of
conditions
right and so the language has to change
towards i have a tendency towards right
or i have a proclivity for rather than i
am
which is definitive certain and end of
case meaning nothing can be done about
it and so if we can change the way we
speak we will change the way we live
because we change the way we think
number one
number two thing that came up so one was
obviously all the i am statements the
what i would say you know limiting
character traits is they talk about
their own traits but the traits are not
things that serve them and so if you
have traits that you speak of yourself
you have to ask yourself does this serve
me does this serve me is this going to
help me accomplish the goals that i have
and if it doesn't then stop saying it so
here's the second thing they did that
was kind of the red flag for me i'm
partially making this because i'm sure
they're going to watch it crutches are
dangerous superstition is dangerous what
i mean by that
is that we have these things that we do
on
these routines that we set and the thing
is is if we become dependent on the
routine we actually become weaker as a
result of it and so that is why i am
always so sensitive to religious and i'm
using quotes here i'm using it in the
literal word of religious religious uh
adherence to routines religious
adherence to you know how i have to wait
like whenever you use terms like i have
to i must i shou we should i need to
these are all things that you're making
statements about how the world must be
when you have no control over it and so
if i wanted to conquer somebody who is a
competitor of mine i would hope i would
pray that they have crutches and
superstitions that i can exploit for
example if you have to drink a bottle of
alcohol every night to go to bed that is
a crutch if you have to smoke a blunt
every night to fall asleep that is a
crutch
if you have to take edibles every night
to fall asleep that is a crutch
if you have to take pills every need to
go to sleep you had as a crutch and i
told you at the very beginning this
video i know this is going to piss a lot
of people off
but believe it or not there were humans
hundreds of years ago that had none of
these things and they slept just fine
hundreds of years ago there were humans
who did not have coffee
in the morning
there were humans who did not have
pharmaceutical drugs
there were humans who did not have
orange glasses
there are humans who did not have these
weird rituals that we try and convince
ourselves
uh we must do we have to do we need to
do we cannot live without and all they
end up doing is weakening us because the
thing is is you have a level of
maintenance right of how you look and
feel whatever
and so what happens is it's like when
you start drinking coffee in the
beginning you feel better
and then over time you need to drink
coffee just to feel normal
and so then the benefit that coffee
confers is gone
and so if you really want to get
benefits from things then you need to
cycle the things that you do which means
inherently you're not going to have a
routine because the things that you're
doing are constantly changing which give
you the temporary flocks or benefit that
it will confer to you as a result of it
being novel if you're going to do it but
most people don't do it that way instead
they become dependent on these
superstitions about how they must go to
bed every night how they must fall
asleep and what they must take and what
they how they have to have their
mornings or what or they create a
punishment for themselves or i can't be
productive or i can't think of straight
or i'm really really agitated all day
right
that's so weak
it's so weak
it makes you so non-resilient that i
would hope to compete against you you
know i mean i would hope that because i
would just hope that something
interrupts your magical routine and then
[ __ ] you for the day
right i've always had the belief that
i'd like to be able to sleep on a cot
somewhere and be just as effective in a
cot with you know
in a corner in a closet
as somebody who has to have every single
aspect of their life completely dialed
in i see it as the difference between
the rocky cut scene of him versus drago
and rocky iv dragon's got all these
fancy science things that he has to do
and all these supplements he's taking
all the stuff and rocky's just doing his
thing outdoors getting it done and so as
entrepreneurs
the two takeaways for this video for you
number one
be incredibly cognizant of the things
that you speak of yourself when you make
i am statements they are the strongest
statements that you can make because
they are deeply embedded beliefs about
what you believe about yourself and so
if you say i ha i am this way when you
describe yourself when you meet someone
new you meet a girl on a date and you're
like i am i have a short fuse right i
have a temper i am disorganized i am not
good with time i am not good with money
i hate even saying this [ __ ] right but
just to give you the types of things
that people say all the time that do not
serve them
does this belief serve me
if it does not stop [ __ ] saying it
period
and say something else
right or at the very least if you feel
compelled to have to describe this thing
then say i have a tendency or i struggle
with behaviors that aren't this way
rather than i am number one
number two be incredibly weary of the
superstitions and routines and religion
that you adhere to
that you claim is the source of your
productivity creativity alertness mental
well-being subject you know happiness
whatever it is
or the converse of that if you lack it
the threats or the punishments that you
speak over yourself if i am not i am
agitated i have a short fuse i can't
focus i'm not productive i don't have
energy all of these things are just
weaknesses that you literally build into
yourself so stop
that's all i got for today guys so
moseynation i make this channel uh
because a lot of people are broke and i
don't want to be one of them and a lot
of people speak limiting beliefs over
themselves they claim traits that do not
serve them and they make superstitions
and crutch that make them weaker rather
than stronger and if you want to survive
in the world of business you want to
build a huge enterprise you want to make
the impact that you have you have to be
able to know exactly who you are you
have to speak beliefs that serve you and
you have to be able to succeed
independent of circumstance that you
create
you are source
not reaction
lots of love keeping awesome catch you
guys soon bye